[indistinct chatter]
[sighs]
Here is your white wine.
- Thank you.
- You are welcome.
Hey, Pete.
Little--
little thirsty tonight?
Ha, yeah.
Super thirsty.
[laughs]
Pete,
this is Haraysa.
Haraysa, this is Pete.
Haraysa just got back
from Africa.
Oh, Africa.
Anyways, uh, where was I?
Oh, the AUC.
Oh, right,
so this conflict
is exactly the reason
the African Union Commission
was put in place
to address.
(Haraysa)
The organization
of African Unity
certainly wasn't
gonna do anything.
Oh, exactly.
And if Nkosazana Dlamini-Zuma
wants to do anything
about Bangui,
she's certainly
being quiet about it.
The worst part about Bangui
is that no one knows
what's going on.
Oh, no, I know.
I mean,
look at right next door,
the South Sudan.
Here's the thing.
Everybody just thinks
that it's like--
that it's the damn
Lion King over there.
You know?
Lion King.
Excuse me?
It's not
The Lion King.
Exactly.
I mean,
what do people think?
A...
baboon is going
to hold a lion cub
over a rock,
up to the sun,
while all
the little animals sing?
Anyway...
Um...
So I also wanted
to mention is,
they have the manpower,
because AMISOM
has 25,000 troops
just sitting there
in Somalia.
It's not a "three
animated hyenas" situation.
That doesn't make
any sense.
The bad guy isn't Scar
over there.
Um...yeah.
Yeah, that's right.
It's not like
Scar's the bad guy.
Well, I mean, you know,
the truth is,
no one knows who to blame,
because in reality,
AMISOM doesn't have
that much control.
- They don't.
- Like Simba.
Oh, like Simba.
He had no control over--
Well, he was plucked out
from his home
and went on a whole journey
before he came back
and was just
in the middle of a war.
Really had nothing
to do with him.
You know, Pete,
I'd be really interested
in hearing your thoughts
on the UN's policies
in East Africa.
Hakuna matata.
[scoffs]
Unbelievable.
Yes.
My God,
that sums it up perfectly.
There's so much work
still to be done.
Yes, that's what
I was saying.
This has been going on
for so many years.
So many years,
Circle of Life.
Hmm.
Exactly,
that's really brilliant.
I'm not brilliant.
Let's dial it back.
I'm just a man.
Okay, uh, I'm gonna--
I'm gonna go get
some hors d'oeuvres.
Okay, no need
to announce it.
What are your thoughts
on the Middle East?
Aladdin.
Huh.